how hard is it
to build a video game like virtual
reality game
where it is so real
forget like ultra realistic to where
you can't tell the difference but like
it's so nice that you just want to stay
there
you just want to stay there and you
don't want to come back
do you think that's um you think that's
doable within our lifetime
within our lifetime probably yeah i eat
healthy i live alone
uh does that make you sad that there
will be like um
like population of uh kids that
basically spend
95 percent 99 of their time in a virtual
world
very very hard question to answer um
for certain people it might be something
that they really
derive a lot of value out of derive a
lot of enjoyment and like happiness out
of
and maybe the real world wasn't giving
them that that's why they did that so
maybe it is good for certain people
so ultimately if it maximizes happiness
right i think judge yeah i think if it's
making people happy maybe it's okay
again i think it's this is a very hard
question
you